- We always like to end the show
with a gem of inspiration
from social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(brief transition music plays)
This story starts 15 years
ago when a then-aspiring actor
from Utah was visiting New York City.
A complete stranger gave him
$200 to see a Broadway show.
It's a moment that always stuck with him.
Cut to 2022,
and Claybourne Elder is
now a successful actor
in his own right.
Starring in Company on Broadway
and in one of my favorite
TV shows, The Gilded Age.
And thanks to a little recent serendipity,
he's now helping hundreds
of total strangers see
Broadway shows for free.
We have him on the line
right now watching on NBC 4
New York at three.
What's up Claybourne?
(audience cheers)
- How are you? Thank you for having me.
- Oh my God, it's so nice,
first of all to meet you.
I love you.
Um, it's great to meet you.
But you only set out
to give away one pair of tickets, right?
- That's right.
Yeah. It was late in 2021.
I got sick with Covid and was
out of my Broadway show for a few weeks.
And when I came back I wanted
to do something to celebrate
you know, coming back.
So I posted on Instagram that
I was giving away two tickets
to anyone who couldn't afford them.
And you know, I'd never reconnected
with the man who gave me the tickets
or the money for the tickets years ago.
But I kind of wanted to honor his kindness
in some way and pay it forward.
And, um. Pretty
immediately, things blew up
and somebody leaked my Venmo account
and people started sending
me money to buy more tickets
from all over the place.
Some people sent me a thousand dollars
some people sent me $2.
- Wow.
- They just sent whatever they could.
And instead of giving away two tickets,
I gave away 68 tickets to
that first performance.
(audience cheers)
- Wow.
- In what I'm now calling
City of Strangers.
- That's so cool.
So how big is City of Strangers now?
- Well, we've given away 1600 tickets,
valued at over $25,000.
And when I look back
at that man who gave me the
money all those years ago,
his kindness really
made me a kinder person.
And that's the kind
of thing I'm hoping to
inspire in some way.
- Yeah.
- To...for people.
And this is really crazy, but, um-
(audience cheers) thank you.
And this is really crazy, but he uh-
I posted it, and it went
viral and because of that
somebody saw that picture
and recognized him and reconnected us.
- Wow.
- So I got to reach out to him
and tell him what he
did for me 15 years ago.
- [Kelly] Aww, that's so cool.
- And now we're friends
and we text all the time
and we just sort of knew
that we were supposed to
be in each other's lives.
- That is so cool.
I mean, you're changing so many lives
and inspiring so many people.
Cuz I remember, I was a sophomore
on a scholarship with a choir program.
I wouldn't have been able to afford it
and because people paid
the money, I was able to go
and see the shows with
everybody from Texas.
And seeing "Les Mis"
as a sophomore in high
school, like changed my life.
It was so beautiful.
And I was like, I wanna be on stage.
And it was like the big thing
that that drove me to that.
So you're helping inspire
so many future actors
and singers out there.
So that's really cool.
Thank you so much, much Claybourne.
I'm liking your post right now. All right?
- Thank you.
- All right, so that's
not all. Our season-long
partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2 the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson
Show, want to honor truly
unstoppable people and
kind people just like you.
So they're gonna be writing City
of Strangers a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheering)
- Amazing.
Thank you very much.